[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في الحساد معكم زين
العابدين توفيق وبينما نتحدث الان تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى ونبدا من هذه الجلسه
المستمره في مجلس الامن الدولي تناقشه
الامن الوضع في السودان المدعي العام
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه حذره في هذه
الجلسه قبل قليل من تكرار التاريخي نفسه
حينما اضطر مجلس الامن لاحاله السودان
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
[موسيقى]
ومن يرقى الى طرابلس تردوا لهذه الصور في
من ليبيا على وقع منع اعضاء بالمجلس
الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا من السفر بعد حجز
جوازاتهم وهنالك حديث ايضا من البعثه في
ليبيا عن اعمال خطف واعتقال تعصفي واختفاء
قصري لمواطنين وشخصيات عامه
وهذه الصور تريدنا الان من كييف في عقاب
موجه هجمات بالمسيرات اوقعت ضحايا
في مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنايات الدوليه
يؤكد فتحه تحقيق في مقتل 87 مدنيا غربيه
دارفور من قبل قوات الدعم السريع ضمن
الصراع المحتدمه في السودان ويقول ان
الانتهاكات المستمره تنذر بتكرار التاريخ
عندما احيل السودان الى المحكمه الجنائيه
واجتماع القاهره لدول جوار السودان يشدد
على ضروره وقف التصعيد وبدء حوار بين كل
الاطراف
غداه زياره الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
الاجرين وتاكيده وحده الامن والشعب مصادر
وامنيه اسرائيليه تقول ان حكومه نتنياهو
اصدرت تعليمات لتجميد العمليات العسكريه
في جنين بعد اتفاق مع الجانب الفلسطيني
وذلك لتمكين اجهزه الامن الفلسطينيه من
استعاده السيطره التي فقدتها في المنطقه
وتزامنا مع هجمات بالمسيرات على كييف خلفت
قتيلا وجرحى واشنطن تقول ان الرئيس
الروسيه خسر الحرب وتؤكد تسليم القنابل
العنقوديه لاوكرانيا وبوتين يقول ان
امدادك بالاسلحه الجديده لن يغير شيئا في
ساحه المعركه وان موسكو لا تعارض الضمانات
الامنيه
لكن لا تريد ان تكون على حسابها
في ختام قمه الامريكيه مع دول الشمال
الاوروبي في السنكي المنضمه حديثا
واشنطن تكشف عن خطط لتعاون دفاعيه جديده
وتعهد بمواصله دعم اوكرانيا ومناقشات بشان
امن القطب الشمالي في مواجهه نفوذ صيني
وروسي يتعزز في المنطقه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا ما اسفر عنه اجتماع دول
جوار السودان في القاهره من تشديد على
ضروره وقف التصعيد العسكري في السودان
والانخراط في حوار جامع وذلك تزامنا مع
اعلان مكتب حقوق الانسان التابع للامم
المتحده عن مقتل 87 شخصا دفنوا في مقبره
جماعيه في غرب دارفور بالسودان المجلس حمل
قوات الدعم السريع المسؤوليه عن ذلك
باستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي كيف ينعكس
الكشف عن مقبره جماعيه غرب دارفور على
جهود وقف التصعيد
وهذه هي الاجابات التي وردت الينا اربعه
واربعون في المئه توقعوا ان يعدل ذلك من
جهود الوساطه بينما راى سته وخمسون في
المئه ان مساعي الحل في طريقها نحو مزيد
من التعقيد
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت على
عبر مسح رمز الكيو ار الظاهر الان على
الشاشه
لقاؤنا في المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتبعون في الحصديين ايضا
بعد ايام من اضطرابات شاركتها صفاقس بتونس
اوضاع متفاقمه ومصير مجهول لمئات
المهاجرين الافارقه في تونس
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم كما ذكرنا يعقد مجلس الامن
الدولي في هذه الاثناء جلسه تناقش الوضع
في السودان واعلن المدعي العام للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه الكريم خان في هذه
الجلسه فتح تحقيق بجرائم الحرب في السودان
واضاف بان المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بسرد
التحقيق في مزاعم مزاعم عن قتل سبعه
وثمانين مدنيا غربا دارفور من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع مضيفا ان المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه تتلقى تقارير بشان انتهاكات
السودان انتهاكات في السودان تنذر بان
يعيد التاريخ نفسه حيث اضطر مجلس الامن
الى احاله ملف السودان الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
للتعرف على مجريات هذه الجلسه بمجلس الامن
الدوليه بشان السوداني ينضم الينا من مقر
الامم المتحده في نيويورك مراد هاشم مراسل
الجزيره اذا اعلن كريم خان عن فتحي تحقيق
في اتهام مجلس حقوق الانسان للدعم السريع
بدفن 87 شخصا في مقبره جماعيه ما هي
التفاصيل
مرحبا زين بالفعل وهو تعهد ايضا بالتحقيق
في اي انتهاكات وجرائم قد ترتكب خلال
اعمال القتال الجاريه في السودان هو في
الواقع في احاطته نصف السنويه اليوم قدم
الصوره الاكثر قتامه التي نسمعها منه في
احاطاته المتكرره امام مجلس الامن الدولي
قال ان تسعين يوما من القتال انتشر فيها
انتشرت فيها الاعمال القتاليه خارج
العاصمه الى انحاء مختلفه من السودان وان
ذلك يترك تبعات
قاسيه على المدنيين في العديد من المناطق
الذين باتوا يعانون
ويخشون على حياتهم وامنهم واعمالهم
ومنازلهم التي تتعرض في كثير من الحالات
للاحتراق
اضافه الى اشارات عن اعمال العنف واعتداء
هو ايضا قال ان التاريخ
كما تفد تشير هذه الانتهاكات يكرر نفسه
حينما اضطر مجلس الامن في عام 2005 الى
حاله الوضع في السودان على محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه بموجب القرار تحت قرار تحت الفصل
السابع رقم 15 وثلاثه وتسعين هو وجه رساله
واضحه
للاطراف الصراع حينما قال اوجه نداء لكل
قائد وكل جندي من ان اي انتهاكات ضد
المدنيين والنساء والاطفال والمنشات
المدنيه مدارس ومستشفيات وخلاف ذلك تعد
انتهاكا
للاتفاق روما وبالتالي هي تمثل جرائم حرب
وان هذه الجرائم سوف يتم التحقيق فيها
وسيتم المحاسبه عليها عبر محاكمات عادله
كما قال هو دعا مجلس الامن ايضا في ذات
الوقت الى ان يتصرف بسرعه لحمايه المدنيين
ايضا قال ان الانتهاكات المشار اليها
وتحديدا فيما يتعلق بمقتل 87 مدنيا غرب
دارفور جاءت بناء على معلومات
وتقييم موضوعي يستند ليس فقط الى مفوضيه
حقوق الانسان ولكن الى مصادر اخرى كثيره
تشير الى موثوقيه المعلومات الوارده في
هذا وهو مع ذلك وصفها بالمزاعم وقال ان
مكتبه سوف يبدا التحقيق فيها بطبيعه الحال
في الطريق من اجل المحاسبه على هذه
الاعمال وغيرها زين المندوب الامريكي نائب
المندوب الامريكي قال ان الافلات من
العلاقات في السودان هو وما ادى الى حاله
العنف الجاريه معربا عن ايضا عن ادانته
للطرفين جراء الانتهاكات النائب المندوب
نائبه المندوب الروسي اخيرا
زين شككت اجمالا في اعمال محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه بما في ذلك في الحاله في السودان
اذ انها تعتبر ان اعمالها مسيسه وتستهدف
بعض الدول التي لا تراها او لا تحددها
الدول الغربيه كما تقول زين شكرا جزيلا لك
مراد هاشم من مقر الامم المتحده في
نيويورك
هذه التطورات تتزامن مع دعوه المشتركين في
قمه القاهره لجوار السودان في العاصمه
المصريه الى وقف التصعيد العسكري ووقف
اطلاق النار وتجنب ازهاق ارواح مزيد من
المدنيين هذه القمه لدول جوار السودان
تشكل في حد ذاتها تطورا في مقاربه الازمه
السودانيه بالنظر اليها على انها شان
داخلي وبالتاكيد على عدم المساس بسياره
السودان فقد دعت القمه الى حوار سياسي
سوداني جامع ينهي الحرب ويحقق طموحات
الشعب السوداني في الاستقرار المزيد في
تقرير فوزي بشرى
لم تكد عاصفه قمه في العاصمه الاثيوبيه
تهدا بما اثارت من روح عدائيه تجاه
السودان كما قراتها الخرطوم بتشكيك الرئيس
الكيني في قياده البلاد ودعوته الى تشكيل
قياده طارئه وبقتراح رئيس الوزراء
الاثيوبي فرض حظر طيران في السودان حتى
جاءت قمه القاهره للدول الجوار السوداني
بمقاربه مختلفه وفقا للبيان الختامي للقمه
التاكيد على الاحترام الكامل لسياده ووحده
السودان وسلامه اراضيه
وعدم التدخل في شونه الداخليه والتعامل مع
النزاع القائم باعتباره شانا داخليا
والتجديد على اهميه عدم تدخل اي اطراف
خارجيه في الازمه بما يعق جهود احتوائها
ويطيل من امادها القبه في القاهره اعتبرت
الحرب الدائره في السودان شانا داخليا ليس
لاحد حق الخوض فيه بما يمس سياده السودان
ويهدد بانهيار مؤسسات الدوله فيه وهذا ما
قرئ من قبل بعض الاطراف السودانيه على انه
استدبار لخطه الايجاد بحسب ما عبرت عنها
على الاقل مواقف عضوي المنظمه كينيا
واثيوبيا ومن يقف ورائهما اشتمل البيان
الختامي للدول ديوار السودان السبع على
ثمان قضايا كانت محل اجماع الاعضاء بمن
فيهم ابي احمد رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي صاحب
دعوه حظر الطيران وتحيد المدفع الثقيله في
الحرب الدائره في السودان فقد دعت الدول
المشاركه في القمه الى مناشده الاطراف
المتحاربه على وقف التصعيد والالتزام
بالوقف الفوري والمستدام لاطلاق النار
والى التاكيد على الاحترام الكامل لسياده
ووحده السودان وسلامه اراضيه وعدم التدخل
في شؤونه الداخليه والتعامل مع النزاع
القائم باعتباره شانا داخليا والتجديد على
اهميه عدم تدخل اي اطراف خارجيه في الازمه
حتى لا يطيل امدها
والى التاكيد على اهميه الحفاظ على الدوله
السودانيه
ومقدراتها ومؤسساتها ومنع تفككها او
تشرذمها والى اهميه التعامل مع الازمه
الراهنه وتبعتها الانسانيه بشكل جاد وشامل
لياخذ في الاعتبار ان استمرار الازمه
سيترتب عليه زياده اعداد النازحين
واللاجئين الى دول الجوار كما دعت الى
ادانه الاعتداءات المتكرره على المدنيين
والمرافق الصحيه والخدميه ومناشده جميع
اطراف المستمع الدولي لتوفير المساعدات
الاغاثيه ومعالجه النقص الحاد في الاغذيه
والادويه ودعت القمه في بيانها الى
الاتفاق على تسهيل نفاذ المساعدات
الانسانيه المقدمه للسودان عبر اراضي دول
الجوار بالتنسيق مع الوكالات والمنظمات
الدوليه المعنيه وتشجيع العبور الامن لهذه
المساعدات الى داخل الاراضي السود
كما دعت الى التاكيد على اهميه الحل
السياسي لوقف الصراع الدائر واطلاق حوار
جامع للاطراف السودانيه يهدف الى بدء
عمليه سياسيه شامله تلبي طموحات وتطلعات
الشعب السوداني في الامن والرخاء
والاستقرار كما دعت الى الاتفاق على تشكيل
اليه وزاريه بشان الازمه السودانيه على
مستوى وزراء خارجيه دول الجوار يكون
اجتماعها الاول في دوله تشاد المعطى
الجديد هو ان قمه القاهره عرفت الازمه
السودانيه بانها شان داخلي مؤكده على
ضروره اجراء حوار سياسي شامل لكل
السودانيين اي عمليه سياسيه تتجاوز فكره
احتكار الحل من قبل قوى مدنيه سودانيه
بعينها تلك القوه التي ترى السلطات
السودانيه بانها هي ذاتها من توسم فيها
دعاه التدخل في الايجاد السلطه البديله
بالعوده الى الانتهاكات في دارفور كما
ذكرنا في مستهل الحصاد كان مكتب المفوض
السام لحقوق الانسان التابع للامم المتحده
قال ان لديه معلومات جديره بالثقه تفيد
بان قوات الدعم السريع وحلفائها في ولايه
غرب دارفور قتلوا عشرات الاشخاص من عرقيه
المساليت ودفنوهم في قبر جماعي هذه
المعلومات سندها تقرير ايضا لمنظمته
التي اعتبرت ما حدث يرتقي لكونه جريمه حرب
يتكشف المشهد من جديد في ولايه غرب دارفور
عن موجه اخرى من عمليات القتل الجماعي
والنهب والسلب وحرق المنازل اجتاحت عددا
من مدن وقرى الولايه لاسيما عاصمتها
الجنينه يخرج الحديث هذه المره من مساحه
الاتهامات واللايقين الى ما هو اكثر وضوحا
ومباشره المفوض السامي للامم المتحده يقول
ان معلومات موثقه اكدت قيام قوات الدعم
السريع وحلفائها بارتكاب مجزره بحق عرقيه
المساليد وعرقيات اخرى اسفرت عن مقتل 87
شخصا على الاقل
عن 37 جثه في مقبره جماعيه بعمق متر واحد
صمد دفنت 50 جثه اخرى في نفس الموقع في
اليوم التالي بما في ذلك جلطه سبع نساء
وسبعه اطفال ندعو قياده قوات الدعم السريع
الى الادانه الفوريه والقاطعه قتل الناس
ووقف ذلك وانهاء العنف وخطاب الكراهيه ضد
الناس على اساس عرقهم
معلومات جاءت متطابقه مع تقرير صادر عن
منظمه هيومن رايس ووتش اكد استنادا على
مقابلات مع نحو 70 لاجئا الى تشاد ان سبعه
مدن وقرى من بينها لجنينه
شهدت اعمال قتل على اساس عرقي استهدفت
بالاساس عرقيه المساليد المنحدره من اصول
افريقيه واشار تقرير المنظمه الحقوقيه ان
قوات الدعم السريع وما وصفتها بمليشيات
عربيه متحالفه معها اعدم جماعيا عشرات
الرجال ونهبت المنازل وحرقتها وسلبت
النساء اثناء فرارهن الى تشاد كلما يملكن
فضلا عن تشريدها للالاف رجال نساء عجائز
واطفال
[موسيقى]
يضربوا
الموجي
[موسيقى]
وعززت المنظمه في رصدها لهذه الاحداث التي
جرت نهايه مايو وبدايه يونيو الماضيين
بصور الاقمار الصناعيه التي اكدت احتراق
قريه مستيري بالكامل تقريبا وخلصت الى ان
هذه الاعمال ترقى الى جرائم حرب تطورات
تشيي بان التحذيرات التي سبق وان اطلقها
مسؤولون اماميون ومنظمات حقوقيه من انزلاق
الامور في السودان الى ما يشبه الحرب
الاهليه ومن تجدد عمليات القتل على اساس
عرقي وقبلي كانت في مكانها ولعل ما زاد من
قتامه الاوضاع في ولايه غرب دارفور انها
تشهد ومنذ اندلاع القتال بين الجيش والدعم
السريع منتصف ابريل الماضي حاله من العزله
الكامله والتعتيم في ظل انقطاع الاتصالات
وانهيار خدمات الكهرباء وتركز دائره
الاهتمام الاعلامي على معارك الخرطوم
وطالبت منظمه هيومن رايس في تقريرها
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بالتحقيق في
اعمال القتل والنهب معتبره انها تظهر
ضروره اعتماد رد دوليا اقوى على النزاع
الاخذ في الاتساع كما اوصت هيئات الامم
المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي والاتحاد
الاوروبي باتخاذ اجراءات ملموسه لمعالجه
هذه الانتهاكات الجسيمه وفرض عقوبات على
المسؤولين عنها بغض النظر عن مناصبهم او
رتبهم
مستشار المبعوث الامريكيه السابق الى
السودان ودارفور ومعنى ايضا من الخرطوم
حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وابدا
بالسيد حافظ كبير من الخرطوم يعني حتى هذه
اللحظه لا يوجد اي تعليق او رد من الدعم
السريع على هذا الاتهام المباشر الذي يقول
اصحابه انه مدعوم بالوثائق وبالادله
الموثوق بها على ارتكاب الدعم السريع
جريمه حرب بقتل 87 شخصا ودفنهم في قبر
جماعي في غرب دارفور لماذا لماذا لا يوجد
رد من الدعم السريع
تحيه طيبه
لضيفك الكريم وللمشاهدين انا اعتقد ان
[موسيقى]
الرد الذي قال به الدعم السريع منذ اول
تصريح رسمي لقائد قطاع غربي دارفور اعتقد
انه يشمل حتى اللحظه بانه مع الاستعداد
لاي تحقيق مستقل لاظهار الحقيقه وانهم
يعني تاسفوا لما جرى في في غرب دارفور في
الجنينه وكذلك اعلموا انهم بذلوا قصارى
جهدهم ال الحيله دون وقوع هذه الكارثه
لكنهم اتهموا ايضا جهات اخرى
الاستخبارات العسكريه وكذلك اطراف اخرى
الصراحه
عفوا عفوا اتهام الاتهام لم ياتي من جهه
بخلاف الامم جاء بتحديدا من الامم المتحده
مكتب المفوض السابق وايضا كريم خان اليوم
حينما تحدث في مجلس الامن الدولي في
الجلسه التي ما زالت مستمره تحدث وذكر
الجميع بان السودان قد يعادوا مره اخرى
الى المحكمه الاجرائيه الدوليه كما حدث في
دارفور من قبل فهو هذا ليس اتهام بالهين
وليس منظمات حقوقيه من هنا وهناك وهو
اتهام مباشر من الامم المتحده
وبالطبع عن الامم المتحده خلال العقدين
الماضيين لديها تجارب عديده مع السودان
وكذلك المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وبالتالي
يعني هناك يعني نظر اعاده نظر من قبل
الراي العام السوداني فيما تقوم به
المحكمه لكن هذا ليس المهم المهم ان هناك
احاديث امامنا هناك انتهاكات واسعه مورست
في غرب دارفور هناك حوجه لتحقيق يعني يظهر
هذه الحقيقه ولا ينبغي الهرب من اي نتائج
يعني لهذا التحقيق اذا كان المسؤول منها
الدعم السريع او اطراف اخرى لكن يعني نحن
في بدايه الطريق نحن الان
نعمل او الجميع يعمل من اجل ايقاف
الانتهاكات والحروب المستمره في الخرطوم
واماكن اخرى الان لا يمكن الوصول الى
حقائق تفصيليه بشان الانتهاكات هناك
بالفعل اعتراض بانه كبير ارتكبت الاطرافها
متعدده المحكمه الجنائيه دوريه الناس تحقق
في هذا كريم خالد المدعي لعند المحكمه
الجنائي الدولي قال انه سيحقق في هذا
الحادثه تحديدا وسيفتح تحقيقا لكن السيد
كاميرون هاتسن فيما يتعلق بهذا الاتهام
المباشر الواضح من الامم المتحده وايضا من
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه المده العام حينما
يقول ان لديه ادله
موثوقا بها
كيف سيغير نظره المجتمع الدولي لطبيعه
الصراع في السودان
لا اعرف ان كان هناك شيء يتغير في الحقيقه
علينا ان نتذكر انه لاكثر من عشرين سنه
جنجويد كانوا يوصلون ارتكاب مثل هذه
الجرائم ارتكبوها في دارفور وارتكبوها في
الخرطوم مازلنا ننتظر التحقيق ل 2019
عند قامت
وقاده
زنجريت بابعاد المحتاجين المدنيين
جثثه ورموا جثثهم في النيل ومازلنا نرى من
قوات الجنجيد مثل هذه الاعمال والانتهاكات
منذ عقود كانت هناك تحقيق قامت به محكمه
اجتماعيه الاجنائيه الدوليه قبل 12 سنه
وكانك شخص علي قشيب جرت محاكمته في لاهاي
لكن لم يكن كافيا وكذلك شاهدنا السلوك
سلوكا جنجويد
وهلا الجميله يبتدي بدله وربطه عنق ويجلس
في غرف مبرده في خرطوم ويدعي رجل دوله
يدعي وكانه
ذلك
قوته لم يتغير اطلاقا ولذلك سالتك عن نظره
المجتمع الدولي لان يعني هذا كما قال كريم
خان يعيد للاذهان ما حدث في دارفور في
بدايه هذه الالفيه حينما وقعت مجازر واحيل
السودان للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه الان
وافد الدعم السريع حضر قمه الايجاز والقى
فيها كلمه يحضر قمم اخرى ويحضر كل
المحادثات هل هذا سيتغير
ما تغير هو ان الجنجويد
عينوا مستشارين علاقات عامه
من الامارات العربيه يكتبون خطابات
ويكتبون تويترات له تغريدات وايضا خطابات
ينشرونها
في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بحث يبدونك
انهم يقوم عمل الشرعي ولكن هم بعيدون
بعيدون عن الشرعيه فكل ما يقومون به وما
يقوم به المجرمون والقتل والمجرميه الحرب
ولا بد ان يحاكموا
بالتاكيد لا ينبغي ان يكون لديهم اي مكان
او فرصه الحصول على التعويضات ستحصل
مستقبلا لما يحصل في السودان سيد حافظ
كبير يعني دعوه فينا
شامله المتحدثه باسم مكتب المفوض السامي
لحقوق الانسان صراحه للدعم السريع هو
ادانه هذه المذبح
وهذه وهذه الفعل التي قالت يوم ترقى
لجريمه حرب لماذا لم تحدث الاداره تقول ان
هنالك التعامل مع القضيه واستعداد لفتح
تحقيق لكن لماذا لم تحدث الادانه لهذه
المذبحة
وبالطبع الادانه الاخلاقيه او السياسيه
الان من قبل منظمات حقوقيه يعني حدثت هناك
اكثر من ادانه لكن بشكل عام نحن كما تعلم
هناك يعني ملفات وتحقيقات مثبته منذ فتره
طويله لكن لم يحدث اي شيء يعني يعني
العداله ومؤسساتها والبيروقراطيه يعني
هناك اجراءات تاخذ وقتا طويلا نحن الان
يعني يعني نبدا صفحه جديده من الانتهاكات
هناك مطالب كثيره هناك يعني مطالب بتحقيق
العداله في جرائم مختلفه الجميع في
السودان ارتكب الجرائم الجيش السوداني
الذي الان يخوض المعارك في الخرطوم ثلاثه
من قادته الكبار متهمون امام المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ولم يبث في هذا الامر
هذا ملف كبير يعني لا يمكن الحديث عنه في
ايام او في حتى في يعني دقائق او في
تقارير محدوده ننتظر نحن منذ مده طويله
منذ ديسمبر ان يتحقق او يتقدم ملف العداله
سواء كان العداله المحليه بالاليات
المقرره والمتفق عليها في اتفاق جوا وكذلك
في الوثيقه الدستوريه او حتى من قبل
العداله الدوليه لكن بشكل عام يعني البعض
ينظر الى ملف العداله بشكل تبسيطي ويقول
بانه يستطيع ان يفهم تعقيدات المشهد
السوداني اكبر المؤسسات مؤسسه العداله
ربما تفشل في فهم طبيعه الصراع المجتمع
المحلي والاليات المحليه تستطيع ان تفعل
ذلك اذا ما توفرت لها لها البيئه خاصه
السلام وتحقيق المصالحات يمكنها ان تحقق
يعني تقدما في ملف العداله افضل من
المؤسسات الدوليه قبل كل ذلك ينبغي وقف
الحرب كما قالت قمه القاهره وكل القمم
التي ناقشت الشان السوداني نشكرك من
الخرطوم حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
ومن واشنطن كامل
المستشار مستشار المبعوث الامريكي السابق
الى السودان
المشهد الاثني بولايه غرب دارفور
السودانيه نتابعه في العرض التالي
يقع اقليم دارفور في الجزء الغربي من
السودان ويقارب عدد سكانه تسعه ملايين
وخمسمائه الف نسمه فيما يبلغ عدد السكان
في غربه حوالين مليون وسبعمائه الف نسمه
تعتبر منطقه غرب دارفور متنوعه عرقيا وبها
العديد من القبائل المنتميه لمجموعات
عرقيه بارزه تهيمن عليها الجماعات
الافريقيه بنسبه 60% من اهمها قبيله
المساليد والفور
تشكل عرقيه المساليد غالبيه السكان بمدينه
جنينه وحبيله بنسبه 60% يليهم العرب
وافارقه اخرون اما قبيله الفور فتتمدد
بالشمال ايضا وهي كبرى القبائل في الاقليم
وتعتبر مع فروعها ثاني اكبر اثنيه في
السودان تتركز اغلبيه القبائل العربيه
بشمال الاقليم ومن اهمها الزياديه وبني
فضل ورزيجات
[موسيقى]
في شؤون اخرى ذكرت القناه الرابعه عشره
المحسوبه على اليمين في اسرائيل عند
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اصدرت تعليماتها
للجيش الاسرائيلي والجهاز المخابرات
الشباك بتجميد العمليات العسكريه في منطقه
جنين واوضحت ان ذلك تم بعد حوار جرى في
الاونه الاخيره بين اسرائيل والسلطه
الفلسطينيه تم الاتفاق خلاله على تجميد
اسرائيل عملياتها العسكريه في اقرب وقت
واضافت انه تم الاتفاقه على ان تقتصر
عمليات اسرائيل على من تسميهم القنبله
الموقوته وذلك لمنح اجهزه الامن
الفلسطينيه فرصه لاستعاده سيطرتها التي
فقرتها في منطقه جنين
وكشفت القناه الاسرائيليه رفض الجيش
الاسرائيلي لهذا الموقف وتشكيكه في قدره
السلطه الفلسطينيه على بسط سيطرتها على
جنين
من رام الله محمد هواش الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي بدايه ما هو تعليقك على ما ذكرته
القناه الرابعه عشره الاسرائيليه ما
المقصود في رايك ببسط السلطه الفلسطينيه
سيطرتها على جنين
اعتقد بان هذه يعني الادعاءات لا اساس لها
لم يؤكدها يعني الفلسطينيون ولا
الاسرائيليون حتى تصريحات وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي
قال بان على السلطه هناك لدى السلطه فرصه
ان تسيطر على الوضع في في الضفه الغربيه
ولكن عندما يتوجب على الجيش ان يتحرك فلن
يتاخر بمعنى ان انه لا يوجد التزام
اسرائيلي
او وعود اسرائيليه للفلسطينيين بوقف هذه
الهجمات والانتهاكات اليوميه لحقوق
الفلسطينيين وهجمات الجيش الاسرائيلي
الفاشيه على المخيمات وعلى المدن وعلى
القرى الفلسطينيه وعلى الضفه الغربيه
اعتقد بان اسرائيل تريد يعني بث يعني
الاشاعات والفتنه والاضطراب في اوساط
الفلسطينيين حول السلطه الفلسطينيه
هي جزء من الحرب التي تشنها اسرائيل على
الشعب الفلسطيني وعلى مكونات الشعب
الفلسطيني بما في ذلك السلطه الفلسطينيه
باعتبارها هدفا للتحطيم وللاضعاف يعني كما
قيل يعني قبل ايام قبل فتره قصيره بان
يعني اسرائيل لا تريد
انهاء السلطه ولكنها ايضا يعني تريد تحطيم
وطحن كما قال بنيامين نتنياهو بالحرف
الواحد فكره اقامه دوله فلسطينيه على
الاطلاق وبالتالي كل التصريحات
الاسرائيليه التي تتعارض مع هذه الفكره لا
اساس لها من الصحه وليست محلي يعني استماع
استاذ محمد كيف تفسر اول زياره للرئيس
الفلسطيني لجنين
حدثت منذ اكثر من 11 عاما وايضا
الاعتقالات المستمره والاحتجاجات عليها
طبعا في صفوف
قاده فلسطينيين لهم انتماءات فصائريه في
الضفه الغربيه وفي جنين كذلك
يعني اولا زياره ابو مازن ليس لها علاقه
يعني بضعف او قوه السلطه الفلسطينيه
للسلطه الفلسطينيه وابو مازن رئيس السلطه
من واجبه ان يزور جنين حتى لو لم يزورها
خلال عشر سنوات فكان من الواجب ان يزورها
بصوره دائمه وهذا لا يتناقض مع فكره ان
السلطه الفلسطينيه موجوده في كل المدن
والمحافظات في الضفه الغربيه
اذا تزمل اداء هذا الواجب الذي لم يتم
القيام به منذ عشر سنوات كما تفضلت اذا
تزامن مع هذه الاحاديث الاسرائيليه عن دور
جديد للسلطه الفلسطينيه في جنين وتزامن مع
الاعتقالات فقد يعني ذلك شيئا اليس كذلك
لا لا ابدا يعني وضع الاشياء بهذه الطريقه
غير سليم ايضا الرئيس ذهب الى جنين لتاكيد
حق الفلسطينيين في الدفاع عن انفسهم
لرؤيه عن كثب ما قام به الجيش الاسرائيلي
من جرائم في في مخيم جنين وفي مدينه جنين
وليقول للمواطن الفلسطيني بان السلطه
الفلسطينيه هي العنوان السياسي للشعب
الفلسطيني والمقاومه الفلسطينيه هذه هي
الرساله الاساسيه لزياره الرئيس ابو مازن
الى الى جنين وليس اي شيء اخر اذا رفقها
اشياء اخرى فلها ايضا يعني علاج ولها يعني
تبرير ولها يعني شيء مختلف كليا عن
الرساله الاساسيه من الزياره شكرا جزيلا
لك من رام الله محمد هواش الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي
وايضا الينا ايضا من رام الله ساري عرابي
الكاتب والباحث السياسي استاذ ساري كيف
تقرا ايضا ما ذكرته القناه الرابعه عشره
الاسرائيليه عن وقف العمليات الاسرائيليه
في جنين مع اعطاء دور للسلطه الفلسطينيه
وتمكينها من اعاده السيطره على الضفه
الغربيه وعلى جنين تحديدا
نعم يعني اولا ينبغي ان نؤكد ان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من الناحيه الفعليه والعمليه
قد ازال حرمه المناطق التي تسمى مناطق الف
وانهى مكانتها القانونيه المترتبه على
اتفاقيه اوسلو منذ عمليه الصور الواقي عام
2002 يعني والاحتلال الاسرائيلي يدخل كل
مناطق الف الضفه الغربيه بما في ذلك حتى
مدينه رام الله ويعتقل ويقتل حتى في
الاوقات التي كانت تتسم فيها الضفه
الغربيه بالهدوء حتى مخيم جنين قبل الحمله
الاخيره الضخمه التي شنها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على مخيم جنين والتي سماها
الحديقه والبيت الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نفذ
العديد من عمليات الاغتيال العديد من
عمليات الاقتحام في بعض كان يرتقي اكثر من
عشره شهداء في اليوم الواحد نعم
فلاتي الى سؤالي كيف تعلق على ما ذكرته
القناه الرابعه عشره الاسرائيليه
تماما الان الذي اردت ان اقوله بناء على
ذلك بغض النظر عن مصداقيه بقالته القناه
الاسرائيليه واضح تماما ان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فاشل ايذاء حاله المقاومه
الموجوده في مخيم جنين يعني القضيه ليست
خصوصيه واستثناء من طرف الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بقدر ما هي خصوصيه واستثناء
لحاله المقاومه المكثفه والمركزه الموجوده
في مخيم جنين
هذا الفشل للاحتلال الاسرائيلي هو يريد ان
يحل هذه المشكله بالقاء المشكله الى
الفلسطينيين يعني بمعنى هناك فشل امني فشل
استخباراتي فشل عسكري فشل سياسي لدى
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في التعامل مع ساحه
الضفه الغربيه عموما ومحاله المقاومه على
وجه الخصوص ومحاله المقاومه في مخيم جنين
على وجه اخاص يريد ان يصغر هذا الفشل
الاسرائيلي الى الفلسطيني ويريد ان يخلق
مشكله فلسطينيه فلسطينيه اضف الى ذلك ان
المجتمع الاسرائيلي يعاني تناقض متفاقم في
هذه في هذه الاونه او مؤشرات متصاعده وهل
ترى مؤشرات على ان الجانب الفلسطيني مستعد
للقيام بهذا الدور
السلطه يعني في الحقيقه يعني اولا لا
ينبغي ان يكون الطرف الفلسطيني اصلا
مستعدا للقيام بهذا الدور بطبيعه الحال
يعني على الفلسطينيين جميعا لم يدركون بما
في ذلك السلطه الفلسطينيه ان مشكله
الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه ليست مع
المقاومه في مخيم زين وليست مع اي فصيل
فلسطيني وليست مع اي مسلح فلسطيني يوجه
رصاصه ضد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مشكله
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه هي مع كل
مستوطنه اسرائيليه مع كل مستوطن اسرائيلي
مع كل معسكر اسرائيلي مع كل جندي اسرائيلي
ومع كل حاجز ونقطه مراقبه اسرائيليه في
الضفه الغربيه
هل ترى مؤشرات على ان السلطه تقوم بهذا
الدور الذي تحدثت عنه القناه الرابعه عشر
الاسرائيليه استعاده بين قوسين السيطره
على الجنين
يعني اولا انا اظن ان السلطه الفلسطينيه
فيما يتعلق بجنين على وجه التحديد هي تدرك
تماما حجم العقبات الموجوده في مخيم جنين
على هذا الصعيد ومن هذه الناحيه واظن ان
السلطه الفلسطينيه تدرك او ينبغي ان تدرك
على وجه الخصوصا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يريدوا ان ينصب لها فخا ويريد ان يخلق
فتنه فلسطينيه دون ان يكون هناك اي ثمن
سياسي بالنسبه للسلطه الفلسطينيه بالتاكيد
في ساحه الضفه الغربيه في هناك العديد من
الشكاوى على مستوى الاشكاليه الفلسطينيه
الداخليه يعني تم التصعيد فلسطيني داخلي
على المستوى الخطابي يعني طبعا من ضمن
اطراف محسوبه على السلطه الفلسطينيه
ومحسوبه على حركه فتح بعد اقتحام مخيم
جنين هذه الحقيقه اشكاليه كبيره الذي حاول
ان يقتحم مخيم جنين وقتل اكثر من عشره
شهداء في مخيم جنين هو الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وليس اي طرف فلسطيني اخر هناك
حديث متصاعد في الاونه الاخيره عن حاله
الاعتقال السياسي الموجوده لدى نعم نشكرك
شكرا جزيلا ساري عرابي الكاتب والباحث
السيسي من رام الله
قالت لجنه هل المعتقلين السياسيين
الفلسطينيين ان الاجهزه الامنيه التابعه
للسلطه الفلسطينيه في رام الله
اعتقلت الناشطه الفلسطينيه عقيل عواوده من
مقر عمله ونقلته الى جهه غير معلومه ومن
جهتها قالت مجموعه محامون من اجل العداله
ان الاعتقال جاء بعد وقت قصير من نشر
الناشط على عوده مقطع فيديو ينتقد فيه
تصريح الناطق باسم لاجهزه الامنيه الذي
قال انه لا توجد اعتقالات سياسيه في الضفه
الغربيه
تصريح الناطق باسم الاجهزه الامنيه طلال
دويكات اثار جدلا ايضا حيث نشرت مؤسسات
الحقوقيه فلسطينيه اسماء ثلاثه وخمسين
ناشطا فلسطينيا لا يزالون معتقلين في سجون
السلطه الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه
ونتابع فيما يلي هذا المقطع الذي انتقد
فيه الناشط الفلسطينيه عقيل عواوده
الناطقه باسم لاجهزه الامنيه التابعه
للسلطه الفلسطينيه
من شوي طلع بيان صادر عن الناطق باسم
الاجهزه الامنيه بيحكي انه ما في اعتقالات
سياسيه في البلد
اكثر من ثمان فصائل الفلسطينيه اصدرت
بيانا السياسي عائلات المعتقلين السياسيين
اللي بتناشد كل يوم يا جماعه الخير
اولادنا بدنا اولادنا طلاب جامعات لليوم
معتقلين في السجون وبحكي لك الاعتقالات
فشل الاعتقال السياسي فينا زميل صحفي من
امبارح صدر في امر اخلاء سمير لليوم لم
يخلى سبيله وبحكي لك فشل اعتقال سياسي
عشرات المعتقلين اليوم مرميين في سجون
اريحا بحكي لك اعتقال سياسي هاي مذكرات
قضائيه ومش عارف شو
تتخبطوش عليها لو سمحتوا يعني انتم
يعني عاملين العمايل بس تتخوثوا
[موسيقى]
الى ليبيا وحمل رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله
هناك خالد المشري رئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه عبد الحميد دبيبه مسؤوليه السلامه
اعضاء المجلس ومكتب الرئاسه من اي اعتداء
لفظي او جسدي وقال المشري في كلمه المسجله
ان اعضاء من المجلس الاعلى للدوله منعوا
من السفر وحجزت جوازات سفرهم الخاصه في
مطار معيتيجا بعد ان كانوا في طريقهم الى
تركيا في مهمه عمل رسميه
من المجلس الاعلى للدوله عندما بدا في صوت
من ثلاث ايام على القبول المبني لخار
الطريق جنه جنون الحكومه وطلبت من الاجهزه
الامنيه التابعه لها
بعرقله المجلس الاعلى للدوله بكل ما اوتيت
من قوه وانه هو سيتم صرف اموال ضخمه جدا
لهذه الاجهزه من اجل
العمل هذا طبعا احنا جتنا معلومات مبدئيه
من يومين وامس طول اليوم كنا نتحدث على
هذه الامور ومحاوله تهدئه الامر اليوم كان
فيه بعض الاعضاء مجلس الاعلى للدوله ذهبين
في مهمه عمل رسميه الى تركيا واذ بهم
يفاجئون وهم في مطار عتيقه بمنحهم السفر
ومصادره جوازاتهم طبعا مش الكل
وتعليقا على منع اعضاء من المجلس الاعلى
للدوله من السفر من طرف امن مطار مع عتيقه
وحجز الجوازات سفرهم دعت بعثه الامم
المتحده في ليبيا السلطات واجهزه الامن
للافراج عن كل المحتجزين التعسفيا
وللتحقيق في اعمال الخطف واضافه اعمال
الخطف والاختفاء القصري في ليبيا تنشر
الخوف والتوتر وتعرقل توحيد المؤسسات
وعبرت بعثه الامم المتحده في ليبيا عن
انزعاجها الشديد من خطف واختفاء واختفاء
قصري لمواطنين وشخصيات العامه من مختلف
الجهات الامنيه
[موسيقى]
الان الى يوميات الحرب في اوكرانيا قال
مرسل الجزيره ان العاصمه كيف تعرضت لهجوم
بمسيرات فجر اليوم ودوت سلسله انفجارات في
سماء العاصمه وقال عمده
ان شخصا قتل اصيب اربعه اخرون نتيجه سقوط
حطام المسيرات بينما اكدت الاداره
العسكريه
تضرر خمسه احياء واكد المتحدث باسم القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه تدمير 20 مسيره اطلقت
تجاه العاصمه الاوكرانيه
وفي تعقيب على الامدادات الغربيه الجديده
لاوكرانيا قال الرئيس الروسيه ان هذه
الامدادات لن تغير اي شيء في ساحه المعركه
مؤكدا انه لا يعارض حصولك ايف على ضمانات
الامنيه شريطه الا يؤثر ذلك على امن روسيا
عضويه اوكرانيا في النيتو كما سبق ان قلنا
تشكل تهديدا لامن روسيا القومي واحد اسباب
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه هو التهديد الذي
يشكله انضمام اوكرانيا الى النيتو انا
واثق ان هذه الخطوه لن ترفع من مستوى امن
اوكرانيا وبشكل عام تجعل العالم باكمله
اضعف وتخلق توترا اضافيا على الساحه
الدوليه لاي دوله في العالم الحق بضمان
امنها بشرط الا يهدد ذلك دوله اخرى
[موسيقى]
مازلنا في الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وفي
تعقيب الامريكي على مجريات هذه الحرب قال
الرئيس الامريكيه جو بايدن ان بوتين خسر
الحرب وقال بايدن انه يتوقع ان تتقدم
اوكرانيا في هجومها المضاد حتى تصل الى
مفاوضات تصب في مصلحتها
لا اعتقد ان الحرب ستستمر لسنوات لسببين
اولا لا اعتقد ان روسيا قادره على الصمود
في هذه الحرب من حيث الموارد وثانيا ستكون
هناك ظروف ستجعل بوتين يفهم جيدا انه ليس
من مصلحه روسيا اقتصاديا الاستمرار في هذه
الحرب لا يمكنني ان اتوقع كيف سيحصل هذا
بالتحديد لكن املي ان تتمكن اوكرانيا من
التقدم الهجومي حتى تصل الى مفاوضات تكون
في صالحها
تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي كانت من العاصمه
الفلانيه هل سينكي حيث اكد فيها التزام
بلاده بالدفاع عن دول حلف الشمال الاطلسي
ومن ضمنهم فنلندا التي انضمت حديثا واضاف
بايدن في ختام قمه دول الشمال الاوروبيه
والولايات المتحده ان قمه النيتو الاخيره
اظهرت اعضائه اكثر اتحادا من اي وقت مضى
وقال الرئيس الفنلندي سولي نيستو ان بلاده
دخلت عهدا جديدا في المجال الدفاعي بعد
انضمامها للنيتو
هذا وقال الرئيس الفرن الذي اذا بلاده
دخلت هذا العهد الجديد في مجال الدفاع بعد
انضمامها لحلف الشمال الرئيس الفنلندي
كان لدينا العديد من النقاشات
خلال العميل الماضيا اريد ان اشكركم على
المسانده الكبيره التي قدمتموها لنا في كل
الاوقات انه من دواعي الشرف
اذا هي هو عهد جديد
للامن والدفاع الفنلندي
وستكون احد من كتب هذا التاريخ
[موسيقى]
وفي مكان اخر بعيد عن الشمال الاوروبي
دعوه وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
دعا بيجين الى اعاده الاتصالات بين
الجيشين الامريكي والصيني بشكل عاجل بل
يمكن التقى نظيره على هامش اجتماعي وزراعي
خارجيه اسيان في جاكرتا وقال انه ابلغه
بمخاوف واشنطن وحلفائها تجاه بيجين اما
المسؤول الصيني التقى ايضا وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه الذي قال انما يعرف باستراتيجيه
المحيطين الامريكيه خلقت تحديات لدول
رابطه الاسيا
المكان جاكرطه والمناسبه قمه جنوب شرق
اسيا اسيا اما الحدث فالقائنا امريكي صيني
جديد في مسار خفض التصعيد بين البلدين هو
الاجتماع الثاني خلال اقل من شهر بين وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه
الشؤون الخارجيه للجنه المركزيه في الحزب
الشيوعي الصيني
منذ اجتماعهما في بيجين شهر يونيو الماضي
لا يكتسي لقاء جاكرت اهميته من ذلك فحسب
بل ايضا مما اعلنته شركه مايكروسوفت قبل
يومين ان قراصنه صينيين استهدفوا حسابات
بريد الكتروني لعدد من الوكالات
الفيدراليه الامريكيه ووزاره الخارجيه
اكتفى بلينكن بالقول ان تلك الاجراءات
تثير القلق وان بلاده ستتخذ الخطوات
اللازمه لمحاسبه القراصنه المسؤولين عنها
يبدو ذلك رغبه في عدم التشويش على جهود
تخفيف التوتر فغداه حادثه التجسس الجديده
اعلنت الخارجيه الامريكيه رصد نشاط غير
طبيعي لكنها امتنعت عن لوم الصين علنا
واكتفت بالاعلان عن اجراء تحقيق
ولا ان تبدو تلك المساعي ماضيه قدما فالشق
الدبلوماسي فانها ليست كذلك تماما على
الصعيد العسكري وهو ما يبدو مقلقا
للولايات المتحده اكثر من الصين
وعليه اعاد بلنكا مطالبه وانجي بضروره ان
يستعيد جيش البلدين قنوات الاتصال
العسكريه بينهما لتجنب الاسوا
وقد ازدادت مخاوف واشنطن من حوادث احتكاك
عسكريه في منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
وفي بحر جنوب الصين التي تجوبها السفن
الحربيه والطائره الامريكيه بعد وقائع
كثيره من ابرزها قيام مقاتله صينيه اواخر
مايو الماضي باعتراض طائره استطلاع
امريكيه في المجال الجوي الدولي فوق بحر
جنوب الصين
ورغم خطوره ذلك الحادث رفضت بيجين وما
تزال عقد اجتماع بين وزير دفاعها ونظيره
الامريكي مطالبه برفع العقوبات المفروضه
على وزير دفاعها كشرط مسبق لاستئناف
الحوار قائمه الخلافات بين البلدين طويله
وفي صميمها معضله تايوان التي تعتبرها
الصين جزءا من اراضيها وقبل ذلك وبعدها
التنافس التجاري وصراع النفوذ في اسيا
والعالم حيث تعزز بيجين مكانتها باضطراب
اما المستجد من الخلافات الامريكيه
الصينيه فعنوانه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث يتهم الغرب الصينيين بالسعي لتزويد
موسكو بالاسلحه ولا تتوقف الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي عن دعوه بيجين
في كل مناسبه الى الاطلاع بدور بناء في
انهاء الحرب عبر الضغط على حليفها الروسي
[موسيقى]
تفاقمت ازمه المهاجرين واللاجئين من دول
افريقيا جنوب الصحراء في تونس بعد
اشتباكات بين بعض من هؤلاء المهاجرين
وسكان مدينه صفاقس اسفرت عن مقتل احد
الاهالي وفي وقت شرعت فيه السلطات وفي
ترحيل اللاجئين الى الحدود مع ليبيا
والجزائر حضرت منظمات حقوقيه من تبعات
الخطاب الرسمي ضد هذه الفئه من المهاجرين
لافته الى ان اوضاعها الانسانيه باتت صعبه
[موسيقى]
مطالب الشباب
لم تكن تونس بالنسبه الى هؤلاء سوى محطه
في طريق عبورهم الى الضفه الاخرى من
المتوسط تاجل حلمهم او ربما تلاشى تماما
في ظل تعقد اوضاعهم وغموض مصيرهم
تقدر السلطات التونسيه اعداد المهاجرين
الافارقه الموجودين على اراضيها بنحو 21
لم يكن ملفهم يثير كل هذا الجدل قبل حديث
الرئيس عن ان وجودهم ياتي ضمن مخطط لتغيير
التركيبه الديموغرافيه للتونسيه موقف
تزامن مع تحركات حديثه لعدد من الحكومات
الاوروبيه بهدف وضع حد لتدفق المهاجرين
غير النظاميين عبر بوابه المتوسط ميساء
الفطناسي الجزيره صفاقس تونس
هذا واعلن السلطات التونسيه انتشالها
ثلاثه عشر تجثه بعد غرق مركب لطالبي لجوء
من بلدان الافريقيه واعلن الحرس الوطني
التونسيه انه فكك شبكه لتهريب الافارقه من
الحدود الغربيه التونسيه في اتجاه صفاقس
تنشط بمحافظه القصرين وسيدي بوزيد ومن
جانب الاخر اكلت هيئه الدفاع عن السياسيين
المعتقلين فيما يعرف بقضيه التامر على امن
الدوله ان دائره الاتهام بمحكمه الاستئناف
بتونس قررت الافراج عن كل من الناشطه في
جبهه الخلاص شيبه عيسى والناشط السياسي
الازهر العكرمي وذلك استجابه لطلب هيئه
الدفاع وفي المقابل رفضت دائره الاتهام
الافراج عن بقيه الناشطين والسياسيين
المعتقلين في ذات القضيه ومحمد خيام
التركي وعبد الحميد الجلاصي ورضا بلحاج
وغاز شواشي وجوهر بالمبارك وعصام
الشابي
[موسيقى]
نعود الان من جديد للمخاوف الغربيه من
الصين وتؤكد كله من الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي على عدم تفكيك العلاقات
الاقتصاديه الواسعه مع بيجين رغم اتهامها
بشن عمليات قرصنه وتجسس في واشنطن نقلت
شبكه
المصدر المطلع القول ان وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه تعرضت للاختراق لاول مره من قبل
قراصنه صيني وفقا لبيانات شركه
مايكروسوفت الامريكيه وايضا البيت الابيض
فان قراصنه مقرهم الصين اخترقوا حسابات
بريد الكترونيه في اكثر من عشرين منظمه
بما في ذلك وكالات حكوميه امريكيه
اما في بريطانيا فقالت الاستخبارات لجنه
الاستخبارات والامن في البرلمان البريطاني
ان الصين نجحت في اختراق كل قطاعات
الاقتصاد البريطاني وان الحكومه
البريطانيه ليست لديها اي استراتيجيه
للتعامل مع التهديد الصيني ووضع البلاد في
موقف صعب
اما في المانيا فقد كشف المستشار علاف
شولز عن استراتيجيه جديده للتعامل مع
الصين تقوم على خفض الاعتماد الاقتصادي في
المستقبل كما اشار تقرير اصدرته وكاله
الاستخبارات الالمانيه الى ان الصين اشار
هذا التقرير الى الصين باعتبارها اكبر
تهديد فيما يتعلق بالتجسس الاقتصادي
والعلمي والاستثمارات الاجنبيه المباشره
في المانيا
هذا السجال الغربي الصيني سبقته ايضا
مجموعه من الاجراءات الغربيه التي استهدفت
شركات صينيه في عام
فرضت اداره الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب عقوبات واسعه على شركه هواويه صينيه
ادت لاستبعادها من بناء شبكات الجيل
الخامس من العديد من الدول الحليفه لواشنط
النسيمه في اوروبا
وفي الشهر الماضي اعلنت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فرض عقوبات على عده شركات في
الصين
بتهمه دعم البرنامج النووي الايراني
للصواريخ الباليستيه وفي شهر مايو يقترح
الاتحاد الاوروبي فرض عقوبات على سبع
شركات صينيه بتهمه بيع معدات يمكن
استعمالها في تصنيع الاسلحه بالحديث حول
هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من بولونيا
ماتشودايل الاستاذ بجامعه والخبير في
الشؤون الاسيويه
اهلا وسهلا بك يعني خطر القرصنه الصينيه
وصل الى هذا الحد لدرجه ان دوله من الدول
الكبرى كبريطانيا يقول برلمانها انه
الاختراق وصل لكل قطاعات الاقتصاد وان
الدوله غير قادره او ليس لديها استراتيجيه
للمواجهه
في الحقيقه
هذه النقطه بالفعل تشير الى توسع الصين
واعمال الصين في الخارج في عدد كبير من
البلدان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
المملكه المتحده المانيا وعدد كبير من
البلدان في اوروبا ينظرون الى الصين على
انها مصدر للتهديد اكثر منه مصدر للفرص
لذلك تحاول الدول الغربيه ان تقوم بصياغه
استراتيجيه
لخفض المخاطر الصينيه من دون قطع العلاقات
بشكل مباشر مع الصين وكامل مع الصين من
المنظور الاقتصادي ولكن خفض الاعتماد على
الصين وما ياتي مع هذا الاعتماد من مخاطر
اضافه الى العمل على
الاعتماد على الاستثمار المباشر من قبل
الصين وتعزيزي الامن السيبراني والامن
الالكتروني
وتفادي استخدام المعدات الصينيه ومنع
الصين من استخدام نفوذ السياسيه
والاقتصادي من خلال الاستثمارات الكل ذلك
يضمن عدم قدره الصين اذا ارادت وفق
المزاعم الغربيه على اختراق اي مكان او
على قرصنه اي مكان نحن في زمن يستطيع اي
احد ان يقرصنا اي شيء
بالضبط ان الوجه المرتبط بالامن السيبراني
يكتسب طابعا
متزايد الاهميه خصوصا بالنسبه الى حمايه
المعلومات الخاصه بالحكومات وايضا
الخصوصيه
والشركات كذلك تود ان تحمي الملكيه
الفكريه لذلك نحن لا نتحدث فقط عن
المعلومات المرتبطه بالحكومات لان الصين
تحاول ان تستحوذ على التكنولوجيات
واتوسع النفوذ من خلال الذكاء الاصطناعي
واشباه الموصلات ايضا هي من بين المجالات
الاساسيه التي يمكن ان تستفيد منها الصين
في هذا الوجه ولكن مجددا الصعوبه في هذه
الحاله بالنسبه الى الدول الاوروبيه على
وجه الخصوص الصعوبه في ارساء من بولونيا
الدكتور مات الاستاذ بجامعه والخبير في
الشؤون الاسيويه بهذا مشاهدينا نصل لنهايه
هذه الحصاده هذه